- [Narrator] Who is the
Speaker of the House
and what do they do?
- The office of the Speaker of the House
is actually outlined in the Constitution.
That's one of the things that makes
the Speaker of the House unique.
The Speaker of the House
does not have to be
a member of the House
although there has never been
a Speaker who has not been
a member of the House.
And traditionally the Speaker of the House
is the member picked
by the majority party.
Doesn't have to be from the majority party
but that's always the way it's worked out
and essentially everybody
in the House gets together
and whoever gets the most
votes of the people voting.
It's just the people voting,
not necessarily the entire House.
Whoever gets the most votes becomes
the Speaker of the House.